bitcoin is used to facilitate an awful
lot of bad stuff it's not just things
like online drug-dealing it's things
like you know viruses which will encrypt
your hard disk and hold you up to ransom
from the original cryptolocker through
things like wanna cry and in the old
days
kidnapping just didn't work because you
couldn't get the money away and the
existence of cryptocurrencies changes
that in ways that may have wider
ramifications what we've been looking at
is how you go about tracking stolen
bitcoins suppose you are foolish enough
to let people know that you've got ten
million dollars worth of bitcoins and
somebody comes into your house and
sticks a gun up your nostril and gets
you to transfer them to him how can you
go about tracing the stolen loot well
people have known since the beginning of
Bitcoin that you can in fact trace stuff
because the blockchain is entirely
public and all the transactions are
there for everybody to see but how do
you go about doing this in practice
people like Martha Mercer and Ryan or
Burma come up with a couple of
approaches the first approach they said
is poison tinting and poison tinting
means that if you put a bad Bitcoin into
a transaction or address then it poisons
everything that's there so if you open a
new wallet and you put in three stolen
bitcoins and then seven freshly mined
bitcoins then when you go and spend that
utx or it's ten stolen bitcoins the
problem with this is that over a few
thousands or tens of thousands of blocks
it completely poisons the entire
blockchain at least the active
blockchain that people are using for
trading so the second method that they
come up with was what they call haircut
tinting and here if you put three stolen
bitcoins into a new wallet and then
seven freshly mined ones then you end up
spending ten bitcoins each of which is
30% tinted and you just write the
software as a track all this now the
problem with haircuts hansung is that
within a few thousand blocks you end up
with all the active bitcoins in the
blockchain being tainted just a little
bit under 10% because something over 6%
of all bitcoins have been stolen at
least once so what can we do about this
well the breakthrough came when I was
talking with David Fox who was one of
our law lecturer us and there's now a
law prophet Adam
and he pointed me to what lawyers and
there was Clayton's case and this was a
judgment of the High Court in London in
1816 after a bank went bankrupt and
during the Napoleonic war and they had
to sort out who owned what among the
rubble and the master of the rolls one
of the senior judges in England at the
time ruled that you had to do frost in
first out right the first money that
went into an account is used to satisfy
the first checks that are drawn on it
and so this gives us a sound legal basis
for trying to do some computer science
because first in frost ice or Pfeiffer
was something that programmers and
communications engineers understand very
very well so we went and wrote some
software which does a 5 for tens of the
blockchain and so whenever coins are
stolen and put in a transaction perhaps
join with other kinds the coins that
went in first or the coins that go out
the first Satoshi in is the first
Satoshi owes and so on and when we run
this oral the blockchain we find that a
fascinating thing happens that the tint
remains concentrated rather than being
spread out so for example if you look at
a theft of about a thousand bitcoins in
2014 and trace it forward to 2016 then
if you use poison tinting or haircut
tinting then it affects about one and a
half million addresses which is a lot
however if you use five foot tinting
then only eleven thousand addresses are
affected so what's happening here is
that bad bitcoins tend to keep on
circulating in bad neighborhoods of the
internet and we find that whereas you
know with haircuts handing most of the
bitcoins out there are tainted one way
or another if you use five for tenting
then the majority of bitcoins aren't
tinted at all the tint is concentrated
among oh gosh about twenty percent or
sort of the Bitcoin stock all of a
sudden we've got a practical way to
trace stolen bitcoins forth over the
short term if somebody came and did an
armed robbery at your house yesterday
and over the medium term if a Bitcoin
exchange goes bust and it turns out that
somebody inside it has been stealing
bitcoins for a year or so so it's fit
for both purposes
has got all sorts of interesting
implications now that the regulator's
have started insisting that Bitcoin
exchanges be regulated now the US
Financial Crimes enforcement Network
which as part of the US Treasury started
requiring Bitcoin exchanges to be
regulated in 2013 they busted btc-e
which was a big criminal operated
Bitcoin exchange in Greece and they went
and busted a few places in America as
well and so now the message has got
across and even in you know relatively
remote places like the Philippines
they've now got rounds passing laws
saying that all Bitcoin exchanges have
got to register as foreign exchange the
others and that means that when you
change bitcoins
whether in two dollars or euros or
pounds or even in two pieces you've got
to produce your passport and a couple of
utility bills so that there's a record
of who you are the European Union for
its part has decided it when the amend
the fourth anti-money laundering
directive that they're going to require
companies who provide hosted Bitcoin
wallet services to also fall under the
regulation and this means that if you
get your Bitcoin wallet run online by a
service company as the great majority of
Bitcoin users do then you have to
provide your passports and your gas
bills just as if you were opening an
account at HSBC there's an interesting
top-level view of this which is that
very often when a new disruptive
technology comes along people build
systems and they completely ignore the
existing laws for a while and they try
and build something better and if they
do build something better then it gets
you know blessed with regulation and
absorbed into the system uber comes
along and it says we're not a taxi
company we're a service company we're a
platform and so they start providing
cheap taxi rides in London and then
people notice that some of the cars are
unsafe that the drivers are working 16
hours a day that they're getting less
than minimum wage that they're not
getting criminal records background
checks that sometimes they read
customers and the crimes aren't reported
and eventually the Mayor of London says
listen pal you are a taxi company and
we're pulling your license see you in
court and the moral is that very often
when you get a new and disruptive
phenomenon coming a lot
you can sort it out perfectly well by
applying existing law to it once you can
figure out an intelligent way to do that
and so what we've done is produced
software which enables you to track
stolen bitcoins effectively and we're
going to be making this publicly
available so that if you're a Bitcoin
gets stolen you can apply it to the dot
the blockchain and you can find where
your property's gone and we're also
going to be publishing a tension which
will be a public list of coins that have
been publicly reported to be stolen and
we hope that that will be taken over by
the authorities perhaps by Europol or
something like that and will then have
to be taken into account by Bitcoin
exchanges when they ponder whether to
give value for a piece of cryptocurrency
that somebody's offered them if I'm
holding some Bitcoin and as far as I
know legitimately why do I want to go
and find out if they might actually be
stolen well this is a prote this is a
perpetual problem with anti money
laundering
measures in that nobody actually wants
to know the truth right Citibank what
doesn't want to know they've got John
Gotti as a customer and they would push
back very very hard against laws which
said that Citibank see you had to go to
jail if it turned out that a mafia boss
was a customer so instead the lobby for
laws which say that so long as Citibank
has got a passport and two gas bills off
every customer they don't have to go to
jail and so mr. Gotti is good at finding
passports and gas bills and Citibank
doesn't have to go to jail and
everybody's happy and so we've got our
source at a an equilibrium in the anti
money laundering
world of traditional money that doesn't
really quite work however once you move
into the world of cryptocurrencies the
fact that cryptocurrencies are
completely traceable changes the game
entirely it you know once you have got
public information of what money went
where and when it suddenly becomes
impossible to but for banks at SunRail
and say now hang on a minute we didn't
know
so the Bitcoin people have been lobbying
for at least five years to have bitcoins
to be declared money because if Bitcoin
becomes a money then now what if there
was a secret mathematical relationship
between P and Q would that change
anything what if he was actually equal
to some multiple of Q